foreign
of the world's population live near the
coast
so we've got sea level rise intense
storms and by some estimates
half a billion to a billion people will
be adversely affected by
what's going to happen in the coast
but that's not the only problem
it's a bit more complicated than that
it's not just storms are increasing sea
level rise is uh is going to flood these
these areas you have secondary issues
such as
acidification that's going to damage
coral reefs and natural systems
you have changing wind patterns because
ocean temperatures are increasing
and storms are getting more intense and
also more unpredictable
and on top of that you've got increased
rainfall
and
flooding that is happening deeper in the
coast in coastal communities
this is a big problem
and it's a it's a personal problem for
me as well I'm from Singapore an Island
state in Southeast Asia many Coastal
communities
I worry about what's going to happen to
to my region how it's going to impact my
family I've got three boys that you know
have grown up along the coast
and with that I've spent the last two
years helping countries and Coastal
communities build resilience against
climate change
what's the challenge
the challenge is no two coasts are alike
they're highly diverse physically
diverse they have different
distributions of populations and they're
socio-economically different in in terms
of the communities that live there
now there are many solutions to protect
the coast
you have sea walls storm barriers we can
restore mangroves and this can protect
the coast the challenge is not so much
the solutions the challenge is actually
what's the right mix of solutions that
fits the local context and delivers the
highest socio-economic return
now let me as illustrate this with with
an example
I worked for with a government in
Southeast Asia
a country with
a large population diverse set of of
islands many Coastal communities spread
across
and one region in in particular faced a
complex interplay of challenges
rising sea levels that were causing
permanent flooding
increasing storms they were damaging the
coast
a large proportion of vulnerable people
in poverty living in low-lying areas on
top of that land substance that made
matters worse
so we worked with the government to
model the impact of climate change
over the coming decades to answer
questions like
which parts of the course will be
flooded
which populations will be impacted
where would schools hospitals critical
infrastructure be be damaged how will
this impact crops water systems
what would be the impact on natural
ecosystems that are important to this uh
to this to this country
and importantly what this did was that
it combined climate science
with data analytics
with local context and linked it to
socio-economic impact
now to give an example one particular
Community faced the risk of a hundred
thousand people potentially being
displaced because of increasing sea
levels eight percent of the economy and
almost half of the Region's Wetland
reserves were were at risk of uh of of
being damaged
now in in addition with this Insight
that the government was able to better
understand the knock-on effects that
this would have on public health on food
security
on forced migration so a lot of issues
so what do you do about that right I
mean this massive exposure and nuclear
answers in what you do and in a
developing economy like such as this
massive trade-offs that you need to
manage in terms of where you deploy
resources
so
initially this region was looking at
building sea walls
having early Warning Systems storm
barriers in place that required a fair
bit of of capital and investment
in fact what we found was that a mix of
solutions were needed so that included
Mangrove Restoration in selected areas
as natural defense and and only in
certain parts of the coast investing to
build storm barriers and and sea walls
now with that
the region could consider
with the same amount of resources
maximizing live saved live views
protected and ecosystem safeguarded
and on top of this
the cost of inaction of not doing
anything also meant massive
negative impact for the private sector
so private Enterprises would have had
billions of dollars of losses with
manufacturing with critical
infrastructure with commercial real
estate being damaged now having a
visibility on this the government could
then engage the private sector on
co-developing and co-funding solutions
that benefited both private Enterprise
and the local community
now this is not a problem only in
Southeast Asia
a city in West Africa for example had
similar challenges but compounded with
very dense populations along the coast
severe land subsidence
and drainage challenges that uh that
were were exacerbated by for Solid Waste
Management in some parts of the of the
city
Now by integrating climate science data
analytics to local context
and tightly linking this to
socio-economic impact the government was
able to manage the trade-offs on how you
would balance the deployment or
resources to things such as you know do
I build more drainage infrastructure do
I relocate some populations to other
parts do I build storm barriers you know
what's the Right Mix
now as you can see this is a challenging
and complex problem
and when you look at it
the challenge is every course that you
look at is different right they're
socio-economically physically different
and the the most pressing challenges are
often in developing countries where they
have limited capacity to adapt
and they have big trade-offs to manage
on top of this
there are many Technical Solutions and
natural solutions out there you can
protect the coast with Mangrove
restoration sea walls storm barriers you
can accommodate by flood proofing
buildings building drainage you can
relocate people and critical
infrastructure the challenge is not so
much what do you what are these
Solutions what's the right mix of
solutions for any given context
so by combining climate science data
analytics to local considerations
tightly to socio-economic outcomes
decision makers can really balance the
trade-offs and take the right actions
over time
to be able to maximize live saved
livelihoods protected and natural
ecosystems saved
so with that
we can protect more people along the
coast
and optimize for the outcomes
thank you